hallo meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video auch beim kanal ihr seht schutz
meiner linken sandra diallo und max
wir haben uns heute zu dritt versammelt
denn wir machen heute einen test wer
mich besser kennt wann ist mein
geburtstag
es ist der kelag nachdenken größtes du
mein okay das schon mal gut geht es mir
irgendeinen hinweis nicht so sagte mona
sagst du auch schon aufs richtig oder
falsch
29 februar und ja 96 21 32 1996
was ist mein lieblingsrestaurant in köln
café de paris ausgeschrieben
auch richtig in welchem jahr wurde man
youtube kanal gegründet den crafter kann
ja ich glaube 2008-2011 richtig war
wie viele youtube videos habe ich bisher
hochgeladen schätzfrage wenn er alles
wieder okay ich sage du hast
3200 320 2954 das ist echt ne 3000 wie
viele bambus sträuße befinden sich auf
meiner terrasse programm zu überlegen ob
sie so einen so quadrat möbeln sind oder
in so rechteckigen 88 richtig wo bin ich
zuletzt hingeflogen war das natürlich
eine sache jetzt eine mitbewohnerin ich
wäre geschäften liegen etwas länger her
nicht nur negative woche monaco
besuchten am montag
[Musik]
als mäßig oder die richtige flugzeug
richtig ich hatte gesehen dass london
scheiße wo wieviel tagen war ich zuletzt
beim friseur ab seiten sind frisch ich
sage
das ist auch eine typische welt kennt
mich besser frage werde 2030 zu woche
vor zwei tagen freitag also sagst du vor
dass auf jeden verlieren das gesagt hat
man könnte sagen eine woche aber es
waren zwei tage was ist mein lieblings
kölsch man trank ja schon das eine oder
andere mal gemeinsam ein kölsch ist doch
ganz klar raisdorf und glaubt manchmal
gefehlt aber ich glaube es reicht oft
richtig wie oft kacke ich pro woche zehn
mal aufgeschrieben
also vielleicht sonst was ist meine
nummer eins fortbewegungsmittel in der
stadt fuß kannst alles nehmen kannst du
tust du bist wahrscheinlich mehr zu fuß
unterwegs als andere zu fuß hatte
tatsächlich gar nicht mehr weil ich habe
nicht darauf bestehen jeweils aus
was ist mein aktuelles lieblingsspiel
computerspiel computerspiel
safer sex ist ein handyspiel was ist
mein aktuelles lieblingslied es gibt so
ein lied das mir gezeigt dass richtig
leid aber das ist nicht so bekannt ja
klar wie viele seiten hat das buch das
ich mit meiner mutter geschrieben habe
[Musik]
wenn ich so zeigen müsste wie dickes ist
es ungefähr so dick und deine dick länge
zeigen wie sich das ja so ganz mein des
buches ungefähr 173 289 sein maxa 289
gesamten wurst 173 gesagt allerdings
sondern arbeiten auch wieder punkt
zusammen schlafe ich eher mit offenem
oder geschlossenem fenster das ist
tatsächlich eine frage die viel über den
menschen aussagen
du schläfst mit offenem fenster also die
frischluft brauchst das ist auch richtig
wie oft habe ich dieses jahr bereits bei
mir gegrillt 3 x 5 x 3 x
man kann auch gesagt die anzahl meiner
handy-apps eigentlich bist du ja so ein
aufgeräumter mensch der so nur so die
essentials hat deshalb ich sag mal 53 96
100 1000 orten und ordner wie oft
rasiere ich meinen bart also muss
wahrscheinlich den so fast jeden tag
basieren bei der seite relativ kraft
jeden tag richtig
wann habe ich das letzte mal alkohol
getrunken
ich nehme mal an dass du gestern nicht
gekommen ist aber vorgestern gestern
ich war dabei kollidiert esse ich lieber
pizza tonno mit oder ohne zwiebeln ist
sie mit die zwiebel
wie viele bücher liegen oben auf meinem
tv tisch das sind so diese bücher die
wir damals in dieser buchhandlung geholt
habe einfach höhere irgendwelche bücher
die sie auf den punkt geben
von welcher marke ist mein fernseher
loewe puzzle als ob von bose drei
sportarten die ich bereits im verein
ausgeübt habe
ok also fußball muss weiß ich denn das
hast du uns so viel anspannung tennis
basketball alter hast du mal einfach so
leichtathletik gemacht
die sache ist ich hab diesen sportarten
wie du gemacht wir waren macht und
turnen kunstturnen ich werde schreiben
wie oft habe ich mir bereits etwas
gebrochen vor
wenn ich so überlege ich glaube in der
zeit wo wir uns kennen gar nicht so
einmal als kind 0 war scheiße es braucht
um so etwas brauche ich glaube doch gar
nicht es sehe ich ein brot mit nutella
mit oder ohne butter ob es richtig ist
mir jetzt egal ist lang ohne butter weil
wenn sie mit mutter ist dann geht
du bist mit butter über ohne ich bin
aber auch mit butter ich hab das wasser
einfach zwei stunden dann nicht
vorgestellt
ja und jetzt ist einfach kalt und weiß
was was ist mein lieblingsjob getränk
ich hätte 21 ist nicht mehr der
lieblingsstadt getränke aber ich glaube
jetzt phantechnikum antwort gab schaut
ja werden dadurch aber er wäre aber du
hast heute noch gesagt dass die berliner
auch luftig mittrinken kannst wie schwer
bin ich 84 kilo schweres richtig echt
richtig 83 kilo macht vielen war genau
so das war's jetzt hier von den fragen
ich habe euch ja 20 befreit sich fragen
gestellt es war zu beginn hat sich
gerade ausgewertet habe ziemlich eng
da war es ein kopf an kopf rennen hat er
ist als ende hin hat sein leider
wirklich habe in der hand gedacht
und du hast 19 fragen sich geantwortet
max 15 fragen richtig beantwortet also
es war gar nicht mal so weit auseinander
allerdings hast du hier mit einem
feuchten händedruck gekommen schade dass
auf jeden fall schon heute die
videowände bock auf den nächsten teil
hat oder mit anderen personen das auf
jeden fall die daumen hoch unter mir
jederzeit und in die kommentare
schreiben
die kommentare wie es euch geht meine
lieben freunde sandra die letzten 3
words bevor wir ins auto komme ich hab
ihn nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßen der
benutzt ausrichtet irgendwo ein video
eingeblendeten smiley drauf täglich
abonnieren in dem anderen video ist
videowall waxenberger gebraten hat
im besten burger der welt im anderen
video passiert was anderes einfach geil
klick was an am sonntag